okay so over to rich hallett all right
well thank you Paul van I'll start by
saying that it's nice to be I guess i
can say that it's nice to be back at
Yale I've actually don't think that I've
been on this campus since the summer of
nineteen eighty-two when I was an
undergraduate visiting a friend to a
student here in being someone has been
really in the environmental studies
world at Cornell and Wisconsin and at
Berkeley and the Santa Cruz and
Dartmouth it's in given that I live only
just a short way up route 91 from here
it's good to have this connection and to
be here with you today I'm I'm a hook to
talk about discounting and I was given
this title discounting in its ethics
which it's I wouldn't have framed it
quite that way I like the title it has
an Indian flair to it or maybe a British
flair to it and it but it does certainly
very much capture the flavor of my
thinking about the problem of
discounting my thinking about the
problem of managing resources over time
and making decisions over time pavan has
jest with you in his introductory
lecture and the T report very much
emphasizes that making decisions about
trade-offs about the present versus the
future are inherently ethical and yet
they have this economic component in
them in my job today is to hopefully
maybe try to tease try to tease some
sense out of that in a simple way now
the discount rate is a key parameter in
the economics of ecosystems and
biodiversity it's a key parameter really
in environmental economics and in
cost-benefit analysis more generally
maybe we should say that discount rates
or key parameters because there's a
plurality of discounting we're going to
see that what this cannot rate one
applies depends upon one's one's moral
orientation and it depends on the
specifics of the policy or the project
that's under evaluation but still
discounting is very fundamental and I
want to start out with the observation
that when we talk about discounting
we're talking about cash flow
analysis we're using economics language
economics jargon and we're using
concepts from finance and so we're using
a particular kind of narrative framing
which is to think that natural resources
that ecosystems and biodiversity are
also that they should be managed as
forms of capital of natural capital now
what is a capital stock I mean the
capital stock is a is a stock that
generates a flow of services over time
and we can invest in capital stocks and
increase the benefits we get in the
future we can liquidate capital in
stocks and which maybe we get a
short-run benefit from but that reduces
future benefits and future services and
it so a capital stock then is a store of
wealth that provides a flow of services
over time now another thing that's
that's tricky and interesting about
ecosystems and interesting about
biodiversity is that there is a very
specific temporal structure involved
here first of all these are collective
goods and services they're not private
goods and services the ecosystem isn't
like a commodity an ecosystem is a
complex entity that generates a whole
variety of services and values that
accrue to different stakeholders but one
thing that we know is that degrading
ecosystems harvesting resources um clear
cutting a forest for example these are
activities that generate short-run
economic benefits so conservation
involves a conservation involves a tuna
T cost we have to refrain from
undertaking activities that generate
concentrated economic benefits to
particular stakeholders often for-profit
firms or maybe it's a crony dictator
government that is eager to cash in a
resource and then spend the cash in some
way and in a way that the investment
that we need to make to obtain future
future ecosystem services is again
conservation and that means giving up
short run fine yet
benefits now when we conserve ecosystem
services and when we conserve
biodiversity the silver lining is that
we if we do it in the right way then
we're providing a long run sustained
flow of benefits you know and it's not
like I buy a car in the car last for
five or ten years and then it's retired
it's more like we conserve the ecosystem
now and if we if the conservation
project is successful if it flourishes
then we obtain a continuing flow if you
could system services over decades over
centuries over generational plans beyond
and so we really need to think about
these two bullet points here as a matter
of what the president what economic
benefits the present generation should
give up so that future generations can
obtain benefits from natural ecosystems
of all different varieties already you
can see I'm talking like an economist I
guess I am an economist of course I know
that that mike christie was here
recently to talk at length about issues
of valuation and values i am the last
person who would say that all ecosystem
services are all environmental values
can or should and be reduced to monetary
values but when we use this metaphor of
nature is a capital asset in investing
in natural capital when we're appealing
to an economics framing we're where we
really are in world where we're trying
to reduce at least to a certain extent
values to two units of willingness to
pay and willingness to accept
compensation so handling these these
trade-offs it involves complex issues of
economics it involves complex issues of
moral philosophy and political theory
and there are experts on discounting
there are experts on on theories of
intergenerational fairness and
intergenerational choice there's no
consensus though in these literatures
and I'm unconvinced that even folks who
are leading experts in the undie
economics of discounting on some level
don't get that we despite decades in
decades of work on this subject there's
still not any bottom line and as simple
as it is leading experts are still
confused about this stuff in ways that
i'll i'll try to make clear okay so I'm
gonna two slides here are in a very
pedagogical way that I might use with
undergraduate students who haven't seen
a lot of economics before although I
learned something new today and that is
the environmental studies undergraduates
at a at Dartmouth College take
microeconomics before the a government
to the Environmental Studies major I
wanted to do school of Forestry and
environmental studies that you take
environmental economics course without a
microwave prereq which but sure I go
there but okay a definition that the
discount rate we can think of
conceptually as a kind of hurdle rate
it's the minimum return on the minimum
rate of return on that that we would
that we would require to undertake a
given capital investment so it's kind of
a threshold you know if a project yields
a really high rate of return it's a good
investment we're going to go out and
make the undertake that action that
yields a really low rate of return you
know we're not going to put our money
there we're going to put it into some
other kind of financial security and
maybe it's helpful here to have a
hypothetical example just to get your
head around this so you can understand
conceptually what's going on with those
okay consider a ten thousand acre parcel
somewhere in the White River watershed
in Vermont their universities nearby
that hold land up there their pension
funds hold land up there well the yale
university does actually or did so a
large intact piece of leon it's been cut
over in the past but think of a good
large tract of land that's got second
I've got really healthy second growth
hardwood forest going on up there that's
what a lot of the woods look like in
central vermont central New Hampshire
where I live now if we manage
for us sustainably we get a whole litany
of ecosystem services one is that you
know if we maintain for us in good shape
then for us it turns out are good at
capturing rainwater and preventing large
floods from becoming disastrous floods
so there's a flood control benefit from
intact for us there's something there
its water quality benefits if we
maintain healthy forest cover than the
water that's discharged into Brooks it's
going to be cooler and it's going to
have the comics and chemistry qualities
that are conducive to maintaining
healthy brook trout populations that's
an ecosystem service there's at to our
recreation there's there's there's
habitat for whitetail deer for grouse
there's firewood these systems that I'm
talking about are not untouched
wilderness areas into England we don't
have wild wilderness for us like we
conceived of in the West we have
human-dominated managed for us that we
manage actually and have managed for
decades and generations to provide a mix
of the ecosystem services what I want to
stipulate behind is that if we continue
to maintain this forest as a forest as a
healthy sustained yield for us then
we'll get services on an annual basis of
a million dollars per year that's not
just one benefit that's everything from
bird habitat the quality of bird habitat
through water quality and all of that
assigning that value would be a complex
very complex undertaking but to make the
do cost-benefit analysis to do
discounted cash flow analysis the
starting point actually needs to be a
really compelling piece of nan market
valuation actually okay the conservation
and involves opportunity costs and in
the late 90 it's coming into the early
knots pension funds were in the Central
Vermont clear-cutting for us why because
good quality hardwood forest yield
short-run profits of two thousand
dollars per acre you can clear cut the
forest dump the remaining land on the
on the on the market and then you've you
have an immediate profit of twenty
million dollars and someone else is
eating this million dollars a year of
we're gone ecosystem services so part of
the problem here is is a tragedy of open
access where it's it's a Commons dilemma
that the different parties are different
are benefiting from conservation versus
resource liquidation and resource
harvesting okay but what we get the
question that is well when we think
about the economics of this of this
problem is this a good investment what's
your intuition about whether whether we
should make bite the bullet make this 20
million dollar investment in in
conservation that's what the that's what
the pension company would demand his
compensation if the Land Conservancy
came and said we want to buy the
conservation rights to this land is that
a good investment for society do we
liquidate the resource or do we conserve
what are some thoughts on that what's
the rate of return on this investment
move on yeah it's a five percent annual
return you know the rate of return on
investment is the annual return divided
by the initial upfront investment so
it's a million-dollar / / by 20 million
dollars which is then five percent and
then if you if you pick through the
details of our chapter on the teeb you
can find that there are plenty of
cost-benefit analysis in the UK for
example who would use a discount rate
that might be three or four percent and
so this investment looks looks favorable
in that perspective I'm getting a little
bit ahead of myself many
conservationists environmentalists are
going to say well look we can serve the
forest we are going to get a sustained
flow of ecosystem services not just for
20 years for 30 years but for a century
and overtime overtime the total value of
those conservation benefits is going too
far it's going too far offset the
you have the timber harvest if we have a
long enough time perspective economists
though is going to reject that reasoning
and that's that's what's going on in the
slide you know in the United States we
have an office of management and budget
within that is is the thing called Oh
IRA which is that part of OMB which
regulates or reviews new and revised
improved US federal on regulations and
when OMB in the Oh IRA process is doing
cost-benefit analysis they use a
standard seven percent discount rate and
that that means what that means what's
it you're you're cringing um it's not
that they it's not that they it's not
that they invest in the US stock
exchange that's that that's that the OMB
based on an executive order that was
first issued by Ronald Reagan and
updated by Bill Clinton says that the US
government should treat regulatory
actions including environmental policies
in some instances as though they were
capital investments and that the US
government has no business taking
actions unless they yield unless they
yield rates of return there are in
excess of seven percent per year no not
if not not unfeeling that and feeling
that society shouldn't be texting the
wealth the job creators and then using
taking money out of taking the wealth
creators the job creators taking money
out of private investment putting it
into government projects with low rates
of return and in the US equity markets
on the stock market the average rate of
return in in the twenty 20th century was
about seven percent per year adjusted
for inflation in OMB uses that as a as
its standard discount rate and the
argument the argument for that the
rationale for that is that the
government should require government
projects government policies to yield
rates of return that are at least as
high as those on the private market and
this is a disquieting result in a way
because it says in my cooked construe
good example that that it's going to be
better to clear-cut the forest we have
with the fact that floods are going to
be greater the next time a huge
hurricane comes and hits Central Vermont
we'll have a bigger flood then we had
even this last time if we clear cut the
the forests that are up in this on those
high slopes that are important for
consumer flood protection and for water
quality on the other hand I can also
find markets financial markets that
we're investors on a day to day basis
except much lower rates of return you
know I hold myself a fair amount of
money in in in money market accounts
which pay a return of about one percent
above inflation you know I'm willing to
so why am I willing to accept a low
return on on money markets while my
stocks may be on average generate a
higher rate of return I mean I have
somebody I have diversify my portfolio
there's some money market with low
return some in the in stocks hopefully
with a higher return not lately really
what's going on there why why would I
why why would there be such a big
difference between the return on a on a
on a risk-free asset I guess I'm getting
ahead of myself wanting it my the middle
of the slide right but what's there's a
spread on the market between the very
low returns that are paid by typical
safe investments like my money market
funds and the riskier an asset is the
higher the discount rate is actually so
in finance people talk about the
discount rate is the sum of two terms
it's the risk free rate of return which
in the data assumes a value of around
one percent and then there's a risk
premium and it's a it's a simple fact
it's a simple observation that the seven
percent average return on the stock
market is mostly a risk premium now
people demand high rates of return on
stocks not because they're impatient or
because they don't value the future but
because they see the stock market swing
wildly up and down and they know that if
they put too much of their money in
stocks then
there's a real risk to their future
well-being there and they require a high
rate of return as compensation for that
risk okay so when we're choosing
discount rates even when we're just
doing very basic economics and we're
using this investment narrative the the
thing is that we need to we need to
choose a discount rate that reflects the
degree of risk that goes along with the
particular project or policy that we're
evaluating the risk premium is going to
be positive for investments that like
stocks increase the overall volatility
of an investor's future incomes gene or
that maybe increase the overall economic
insecurity of a region like Central
Vermont or maybe the increase
environmental risks for a region but
negative risk pre- risk premiums are
also possible a negative discount rate
might be possible when would that happen
can you think of an example
all right yes yes that's a good point
we'll come to that point a little deeper
in this talk if we think that the world
is going to go to hell in a handbasket
in the future we might accept and you
know the discount rate might be negative
meaning that we're attaching more weight
to the future to getting benefits in the
future than we are in the in the present
that's that's correct but I'm also
thinking about insurance you know it in
a niche on an insurance policy i invest
money now and if there's an accident
then i get a payoff on average a typical
typical investor gets less money out of
their insurance policy than they pay in
the rate of return on insurance is
negative but the reason that you accept
that negative expected return is because
when you when you invest in insurance
you're it's a precautionary action that
reduces the overall risk of your
financial situation it's an asset that's
going to pay off in bad states of nature
when you really need the when you really
need the you know when you really need
the money and when I get more deeply
into this talk I'm going to talk about
how this how this reasoning applies in
the in the economics of climate change
but sustaining I mean ecosystems are
complex they're unstable they're there
if we if we degrade them we can lose
written services irreversibly and the
impacts can have catastrophic impacts
actually and have catastrophic effects
in so conserving ecosystems conserving
biodiversity as an investment in
precaution it reduces the overall risk
that's faced by future ecosystems and
the EMA it reduces it reduces a whole
set of risks to future human lives and
livelihoods and just a very basic
conceptual argument is that we might use
low discount rates in evaluating
biodiversity projects if we think that
that that investment in conservation has
precautionary benefits okay okay now of
course the using hi discount rates also
does raise flat-out really important
critical issues of intergenerational
fairness let's think about Hurricane
Katrina which imposed about 200 billion
dollars of damages on New Orleans a few
years ago but now let's think about a
future Hurricane Katrina that hits not a
few years ago but hits two centuries
from today in October you know
september-october of 2211 and let's
suppose that we could establish a cause
and effect relationship you know that
there are actions that we could take
today that would either prevent the
hurricane from occurring or maybe it
would be an eddication response that
would that would make the damages go
away right so it's a hurricane caused by
climate change or its hurricane that's
damaging because we've lit we've lit
coastal wetlands degrade and so storm
surge is more of a problem that it would
have been otherwise and we faced a
choice as a society either we live with
this future impact with with a cost a
future cost of two hundred billion
dollars or we can make an upfront
investment in conservation you know
greenhouse gas mitigation coastal
wetland conservation that would have the
effect of negating that cost that cost
would go to zero just for a simple
example and the question is well how
much should we rationally be willing to
pay to prevent that future impact if
we're good investors seven percent
return right well if we have seven
percent returns on average and we're
compounding over 200 years you know one
point 07 raised to the 200
r is a big number think it's more than a
million what we can say then is that the
present discounted value just a second
the present discounted value of that 200
200 billion dollar future impact is less
than three hundred thousand dollars
today in the short run what's it I'm
going to move on now but I'll move on in
the making an observation that it just
doesn't feel good morally to think that
it's okay to avoid making a two hundred
and sixty-six thousand dollar investment
today you know for the low low price of
two hundred sixty six thousand dollars
we can avoid two hundred billion dollars
of future costs and we know that those
two hundred billion dollars of future
costs involved people drowning in their
homes it doesn't seem morally sound to
think that we don't undertake these
particular actions just because the rate
of return on investment isn't quite as
high as the stock market right morally
we think that that's not sound yeah and
that gets that gift to these these these
these these lines of critique and that
stuff I meant to spend a lot of time in
in the rest of the the hour here talking
through critiques of this kind of very
simple kind of strong beyond reasoning
that I've just laid out for you you know
classical utilitarianism is a is a moral
philosophy that certainly goes back to
Bentham circa 1800 in a way it goes back
as far as Aristotle I think which is to
say that the goal should be promoting
human flourishing and human happiness
and what Bentham added in the modern
period is the idea that everyone's
well-being should count and each person
should count equally andy Tillett Arian
is going to say well we should attach
equal weight to the well-being of
present persons and future persons and
if we take that argument that moral
premise we can construct an argument
that says that we should be using
actually a positive monetary discount
rate but a monetary
the discount rate that's much lower than
seven percent you know and the reason
that we should that we should the reason
that we might discount future monetary
values if we're utilitarians is if we
believe that future generations will be
better off than we are so they at the
margin an extra unit of income is that's
valuable to them than it would be to us
the worst and suffering people in 2011
so that's one argument let's take an
argument and this comes back to your
point t 0 and this will be the last part
of my [ __ ] and it's really my own point
of view regarding these kinds of choices
whether it be biodiversity conservation
whether it be climate change you know
pinch ow Pinchot is some is represented
as a utilitarian but Pinchot's argument
was that natural resources are the joint
property of present and future
generations and that the present
generation has a right to obtain its
share of the benefits but also to
sustain the resource and pass the
capital stock and tacked on to future
generations and in it and that's a
framing that says that the present
generation has no right to impose
uncompensated harms on those that come
after us but that's an invasion of their
rights it's an invasion of their their
human rights possibly and you know
invading people's rights I mean we can
argue about how much I would need to
compensate you if I inflict a harm on
you but your right to be protected from
harm isn't grounded in a cost-benefit
calculus actually its rights and rights
Trump economic considerations in legal
systems generally yeah
oh yeah yeah absolutely no absolutely no
because it's it's that would need to be
another lecture I guess right it's the
there's a value there that's not being
captured to use that I think it's the
team framing there's a value there that
we can demonstrate and then we need to
capture it and there's an institutional
problem that the 20 million goes to the
pension fund the the million dollar per
year and benefits goes to the hunters to
the cross-country skiers to the local
community and there's a there's a
politics to that yep yeah
yep yes over here go ahead you have to
floor yeah yeah well I mean the T biz is
an example of exactly how to do that I'm
going to talk specifically about the
economics of climate change because the
economics of climate change very serious
work has been done including by you know
Mendelsohn and in the house right here
at Yale to try to assign monetary values
to environmental externalities yeah
yeah I think it does and it's I mean
remember that that what can chose
argument was was that for us for example
our public trust resources they belong
to each and every member of society
jointly present and future and it's it's
a vision I mean control was concerned
about taking for us out of the hands of
the robber barons and managing for us in
a way that provided benefits to regular
people in the short run and in the long
run and I think that it's important to
keep it to keep the intra generational
issue and the intergenerational issue to
see if those are both and play actually
and their two sides of the same coin all
right I'm going to move on now and I'm
going to switch to talking here about
climate change I'm going to focus on
climate change for a number of reasons
one is that it's close to my own
research interests both on the economic
side and on the ethics side second dance
that climate change really is a it's an
ecosystem service problem climate
regulation is a crucial ecosystem
service and in protecting climate is at
the core of protecting biodiversity as I
will as well as I'll get into and
finally the recent this the recent
debate over discounting and
environmental economics is focused very
very narrowly actually on a debate
between between Nikolas turn on the one
hand and professor nord has here at Yale
and in focusing on the climate example
then I can I can dig into a current
debate and give you an idea for how to
how I think about it more concrete terms
on how to think through how to apply
these issues okay some background facts
it's dangerous to talk about principles
in the abstract without thinking about
the concrete details of how a principal
is going to be applied when you're
making moral arguments you need to have
you need to think imagine enough Lee
about what's at stake and who the
stakeholders are in the short run and in
the long run and if we immediately go to
an economic calculus then we can lose
track of what's what's really at stake
in human terms we know that since 1900
that the mean global temperature is
increased by little less than one degree
Celsius and let a lot more climate
change this going to be coming in the
coming century whether it's a little bit
or whether it's a whole lot is uncertain
because of uncertainties about chance in
greenhouse gas emissions and because of
the sensitivity of climate and the
sensitivity ecosystems to to change us
in greenhouse gas concentrations we know
too that the Copenhagen Accord just in
the binding policy but it's a gets it
sets a goal and the goal is to stabilize
mean global temperature about 2 degrees
Celsius above the pre-industrial norm so
about one degree Celsius above current
levels and we know that that achieving
that goal would require a rapid
transition away from fossil fuels large
reductions in fossil fuel emissions and
other greenhouse gas emissions relative
to current levels phased in over the
course of some decades in North America
in Europe also in developing countries
worldwide this would need to be done
even 2 degrees Celsius though turns out
from an earth science perspective to be
a lot of climate change that would
return us to the warmest climate that
the earth is experienced in the last
three million years a time when sea
level was about 30 meters higher than it
is today you know we're not going to see
a sudden 30 meter increase in in sea
level because of a two degree Celsius
temperature rise we actually might see
the Greenland ice sheet collapse
although even that would take time but
in the Earth's history this that what
seems from a human perspective like a
small change is actually a very large
change alumium we're already seeing
extinctions from that are clearly
attributable to anthropogenic climate
change we know a whole lot about
greenhouse gas emissions abatement cost
professor gillingham is in that
for in this I should say that these two
Beck are former students of mine
incidentally including one of your
professors which i think is scary I
don't think of myself as well I'm old
yeah I'm getting there but but but can
you know it's this stuff really really
well it was trained at one of the best
departments in the world really working
on on energy economics and the economics
of climate you know stabilizing
greenhouse gas concentrations at 550
parts per million so a doubling
achieving something like the Copenhagen
Accord that that's costly it's not
hugely costly it would over time require
allocating about 1% of economic output
to clean technologies that will be
phased in over time and it and you know
you can do the math that would be
hundreds of billions of dollars per year
right but also in terms of the impact on
the rate of economic growth too small to
see in the numbers but there's a cost
and it's in the hundreds of billions of
dollars per year and we know an awful
lot about how to design greenhouse gas
mitigation policy is in a cost-effective
way they need to be incentive based on
the one hand because you know come back
to the teeb if you're inflicting harm
but you're not paying for the harm well
you don't really have an incentive to
switch to the clean technology even
though it's cost effective you need to
pay attention to taxing externalities
and reducing taxes on things like labor
and capital investment and that's
something that I admire about Kenny's
work is that it it looks hard at this
business about what kinds of policies
are needed to promote the development
and diffusion of low-carbon technologies
that's an interest that that I have as
well especially earlier in my career I
worked on that so there's a cost
conservation is costly and it's a
conserving climate and stabilizing
climate it requires actions today and so
it requires a short-run investment today
but we get we hopefully get a benefit in
the long run a return on that investment
and that return is what it's all
ecosystems services you know for one
thing
it means that we'll have more species
left in the future rather than fewer
species left in the future we'll have
not fewer tropical storms but less
intensive less damaging tropical storms
stabilizing climate will prevent
reductions in crop yields which might be
modest mendelssohn's work suggests the
modest climate change would not have
that large in effect on on climate wolf
going Wolfram flanker who's AG economist
at Columbia Thanks that even small
temperature changes are likely to really
whack agriculture so there's some
there's a thesis topic actually is
slacker right or as Mendelsohn right and
then where's the middle ground there but
that's I think really interesting it's a
hot topic these days um we can look at
sea level rise we can look at floods
droughts tropical diseases you know
again all of these are linked to
ecosystem services you take tropical
diseases Paul Epstein is an
epidemiologist at Harvard who showed
that weather systems off of western
South America can cause can cause marine
events that then lead to tropical
disease outbreaks you know cholera I
believe right what's that yeah so
cholera outbreaks are tied to climate
and they're tied to climate because of
the functioning of ecosystems so climate
and ecosystems I mean are tightly linked
together all right two numbers that you
might their three numbers that you might
want to pay attention to here one is it
in the 1990s early on analysts like
nordhaus like like tall in in Europe
like Mendelsohn here came up with
numbers trying to estimate the monetary
value of climate impacts focusing in
particular on the damages that would be
caused by three degrees Celsius
temperature warming and a typical number
from that early literature is on the
order of about two percent of economic
output and that's still a number that
people work with this is an area where
unfortunately there's actually not very
much consensus about that there are
people to think that that number is too
high there are people think that that
number is way way too low in part
because it's a matter it comes back to
the earlier conversation that if climate
change causes pervasive changes in
ecosystem structure and functioning and
people aren't willing to accept you know
more market goods and services for
ecological degradation then how do we
assign a monetary value to that is that
a meaningful thing to do so the expected
damages if moderate climate change might
not be so high but the expected the
expected ecological impacts of moderate
climate changes or severe you know
Thomas at all in a letter to nature in
2004 concluded that up to thirty three
percent and thirty-four percent of of
terrestrial species could be committed
to extinction by the levels of climate
change that we had see through mid
century the century and that's only two
degrees Celsius and so relatively small
increases in in mean global temperature
will cause very substantial biodiversity
loss that has not really been valued in
monetary terms and brought into the
rubric of cost-benefit analysis which is
a real weakness in the economics of
climate change actually and I'll say to
that clearly climate catastrophes are
possible here on citing a 1994 paper by
Nordhaus who did an expert opinion
survey and you know the question was
what's the statistical probability that
three degree increase in mean global
temperature would would impose economic
damages equivalent to twenty five
percent or more of economic output and
the median answer in the in the sample
is five percent low probability of
really large damages and we're still
there we're still in the world of
thinking that maybe moderate climate
change wouldn't be that damaging to the
economy but they're being subjective
concern about things going terribly
wrong and then really not knowing enough
about the feedbacks between the climate
ecosystems ecosystem services
agriculture all of that to really feel
that we have a handle on the damage
function okay so back to discounting I'm
here to talk about discounting after all
the economics of climate change really
was pioneered very importantly by
nordhaus here at Yale in the late 80s
and early 90s in North houses dice model
is really still the model that all the
rest of us point to you know as a
starting point for analysis even people
who are making it who arguing against
nordhaus Ticknor houses dice model as as
kind of a canonical model that they can
use to make points because if we all
know this model and we all work with
this model and what does it do well it's
a model of a future growth of the
economy and in combination and the
future growth in greenhouse gas
emissions and the accumulation of
greenhouses in the atmosphere and the
biophysical science of global
temperature change and then climate
damages so it's a couple model of the
climate economic system that integrates
the president costs and the future
benefits of Climate stabilization that's
the that's the thing to get at here and
there's a lot of sophistication that
goes into how you would build a bottle
like that now for our purposes a really
crucial part of the dice model which
I'll discuss technically in just a
second is that that Nordhaus calibrates
the preferences of his model so that a
typical capital you know private sector
investment yields a rate of return
that's about six percent per year in
money terms right so it's a six percent
disk monetary discount rate in his model
and that's built into the structure of
the way that he calibrates preferences
in a way i'll describe and then he he
calculates uses this model to calculate
optimal abatement efforts in the short
and long run
and its key result as a result that he
calls the policy ramp that is that
starting from the present you know the
ER case he actually consistently has
argued against taking drastic short-run
steps towards reducing greenhouse gas
emissions what he says is that we should
reduce the future growth of greenhouse
gas emissions maybe in fear can we
should reduce the future growth of
greenhouse gas emissions but only take
only take modest low-cost steps in the
English wart run and defer major
reactions to move to a post carbon
system through to the future okay so
mechanically the dice model like other
models of this type assumes that society
is organized to maximize the discounted
utility of an infinitely live
representative household that's a
mouthful but that's how this works
mechanically it says that society cares
about consumption and here cease of T is
the per capita consumption of the global
economy at dat and we started in the
present and then we go forward into the
future in principle going to over an
infinite time horizon and its population
so what we're doing is we're multiplying
the population size times the utility
that a typical person derives from
consumption at each point in time and
this coefficient alpha is called the
elasticity of marginal utility and that
the term ins the mathematical
relationship between consumption and and
well this is not very good need to spend
more on pants there we go that's not
good either okay so if we have utility
on this y-axis here we got consumption
over here then of course we've got a
concave curve and higher the value of
alpha is limb the whatsit higher the
value of alpha is then the then the more
curvaceous our curve is the here its
utility and then here is consumption and
then we've got a curve that looks
something like this right and so
what's that I met at Dartmouth either so
now we're in the same page we're smaller
than you are but there's a lot of
commonalities and I'm learning so okay
so so this model then it's about the
consumption of a presence of present and
future society and there's two
parameters that are in this model the
first this alpha parameter is the
elasticity of a marginal utility it
determines the Kercher of the utility
function and then there's this thing
called row the puréed a time preference
it's the utility discount rate and row
it went if Rho is a positive number the
higher the value of Rho the less we care
about the less weight we attached to the
welfare of future generations now if you
pick up a textbook on a grad textbook on
macroeconomics you'll quickly come
across an equation called Ramsey's rule
Ramsey's rules suppose that public
policies and economic structures are
struct or set up in a way that maximizes
the well-being of an infinitely live
representative household over time so or
lon the optimal time path for the
economy then along the economy's optimal
path we're going to have a result known
as the Ramsey equation as reims ease
rule and this equates the the the the
market return on investment this is the
the productivity of capital investment
and therefore the the market return on
capital investment we have the pure
rated time preference and the second
thing here are called alpha G ours the
money discount rate nordhaus Tesla based
on his assessment of the data that the
money discount rate should be six
percent per year and this equation it
says that we're discounting for two
reasons one is because we're in patient
the higher the value of Rho the more
impatient we are and the less value we
attach to the future period i'm watching
time to sow second term is called the
wealth effect g here is the consumption
growth rate and what's happening is that
is
as the consumption grows over time then
at the margin consumption generates less
and less utility benefit to people and
so future money values are worthless to
us not just because we're impatient
because we expect to be wealthier and in
the in Ramsey's equation then we have
the psychological you know it's it's we
discount the future because we're
impatient and because we expect to be
wealthier in the future if that makes
that the money discount rate are does
that always have to be positive in this
equation what happens if the economy is
scratching and burning we're going down
consumption growth rate is negative it's
possible that that second term alpha
times G within let's take on a negative
value that says that because we're
getting poorer over time it's more
important to us to take care of future
generations and secure their well-being
than it is to look after increased
consumption in the short run you see
that what's it yeah if that's that's
exactly right so we might accept in some
cases we might at least in principle
except negative returns on investment if
we thought that that we are getting
poorer over time because of climate
change they now nor houses key
calibration assumption is the market
return on investment is six percent per
year and also that the that the
consumption growth rate is 2.25 percent
he takes those two numbers he
substitutes them into his equation
Ramsey's rule and then he assigns values
to the parameters alpha and row that
replicate the six percent market rate of
return that's that's how dice is
calibrated well I'd like you to notice
is that he's got two unknowns in one
equation and you could choose different
values for these for these parameters
that would match Ramsey's rule and
there's there's not there's not a lot of
substance to exactly why he chooses
these two particular values
yeah come on that's what do you argue
yeah yeah well that brings us to
stirring that doesn't it we get the
policy rehab in nort houses argument
because he's to be ending a six percent
rate of return on Climate stabilization
investments and then we're looking at
investments that don't pay off for a
century or two and then a high discount
rate means that we're actually not
really valuing the future are we're
demanding a really high rate of return
on investment and this brings us to a
concept that's called prescriptive
discounting in the in the economics
literature I mentioned earlier on I'm
going to skip the top part of the slide
and home right in here but I already
mentioned classical utilitarianism the
idea that equal weight should be
attached to the well-being of each
member of society and if each present
and future person's so this is a
conception that emphasizes intra
generational fairness and
intergenerational fairness in the same
breath if we're attaching equal weight
to present and future well-being and
clearly we can't have a positive value
for row we can't say that we're
discounting future generations
well-being because well we let's they'll
be unethical to say that we're going to
to to attach more weight some people's
well-being than others that's the
Tillett Arians do not accept that some
people's well-being should count more
than others and a positive fee I you for
row is inconsistent with that now the
stern review is the other sort of
benchmark case in the economics of
climate change and stern picks up this
argument from classical utilitarianism
he works with a model called page which
isn't quite the same as dice but it's
based on all the same kinds of
underlying data and assumptions I mean
that it's the factually it's very very
similar to dice it makes it basically
agrees with diet least in broad terms
about the costs and benefits of Climate
stabilization
we're Stern really disagrees with Lorne
house is over how to calibrate time
preference sir it says okay let's start
out by attaching equal weight to the
well-being of future generations but
stern is concerned that there's a little
tiny probability that an asteroid will
hit the planet so we're going to
discount future utility at a rate of 0.1
percent per year which is almost zero
and the 0.1 percent per year is supposed
to reflect the risk of a calamitous
asteroid event that would be life-ending
but essentially he's choosing a puréed
of time preference of zero based on this
utilitarian argument steren assumes that
going forward that consumption growth
will be one-point-three percent which is
a little lower than norden else is
assuming he assumes that the elasticity
of marginal utility is one instead of
two which is more houses value and then
think about what happens here well he's
got now a value for four row almost zero
a value for alpha value for 4G which he
plugs into the Ramsey equation and voila
he arrives at a monetary discount rate
of one point four percent per year and
he does his cost-benefit analysis using
the page model and guess what he finds
hey any takers what's the punch line
from the store in review
he's arguing that we should basically
implement policies that would make good
on the Kyoto Accord and that that's a
good investment from an economics
perspective taking this utilitarian
approach to discounting and it's the
only thing the only point we're stirring
and Nordhaus seriously disagree is that
nor house is saying it should be a
market rate of return stern is saying
that we should attach equal weight to
present and future welfare but that we
use a low monetary discount rate because
we think that the marginal utility of
consumption will fall over time do you
see that you see that but you're a
finance guy so he has a finance Scott
you know that's scary yeah yep
yeah yeah it's something that's not very
satisfactory it's something that's not
said something that's not satisfactory
something that's not satisfactory about
these models and I've heard Stern
stirring himself specifically says that
he's not happy with the way this is
handle Stern in a meeting I attended not
too long said that if you were to redo
it now he would think more about the
ethics of trying to compress all
ecosystem service values into
consumption equivalence because this is
a model that says that its consumption
that counts and that doesn't separately
viu ecosystem services it comes back to
your point earlier too yep yeah so we're
in it we're in a we're in a bit of a
bind here now we're in a bit of a bind
we shown that if we use a high high
market-oriented discount rate then we
have the policy ramp and we've shown
that if we use the low epic space
discount rate then we have the
Copenhagen Accord arm critics argue that
Stern's approach is dramatically
inconsistent with market rates of return
and people actually don't care nearly as
much about the future astern says that
they do surance responses well maybe
they don't but they should morally so
what do we do I think it's a frustrating
debate it's a frustrating debate that in
a sense hasn't shifted all that much in
since the early 1990s does the SEC since
the early 1990s when a very similar
debate was was most launched between or
house and then William Klein yeah
that's that's this next point actually
yes is the answer now are there ways
forward this is this this particular
framing has existed since the early
1990s in the debate between nine sternum
nor nuts turn and north house but
between client and Lord house and it's
either ethics based or its markets based
and in a lot of ways it's not very
satisfactory because people don't agree
on the ethics and then when we don't
agree on the ethics then it's hard to
know what assumptions to put in the
economic model and then it's hard to do
policy evaluation so what do we do one
way forward is to think harder about the
basic theory of discounting
intertemporal choice and dealing with
uncertainty actually the dice model is
at heart a deterministic model nordhaus
does sensitivity analysis using monte
carlo simulations but base the model is
deterministic and it replaces uncertain
parameters with best guesses of those
parameters and we're using a
deterministic model to make us to make
prescription about a about a problem
that inherently involves a lot of
uncertainty and that ought to bother us
because fundamentally climate mitigation
is a problem of uncertainty you
mentioned Weitzman Martin Weitzman at at
MIT he has made the argument that that
what should scare us or concern us about
climate change isn't the expected
damages of small climate changes but
rather the idea that climate change will
turn out to be much worse than we were
anticipating and the damages will be
catastrophic and irreversible with some
with some very low probability and he's
done it's a very elegant economic theory
suggesting the low probability
catastrophic events that frankly we
don't know how to quantify very well
should drive policy analysis and I'll
give you an example of how to try to do
that okay my colleagues at Dartmouth
might curse who's a bit as PhD in
industrial ecology here at Yale and then
mark borsuk and I or we're
on this and our starting point is
actually to go back to the dice model
and that work just with Ramsay's rule
and match the six percent rate of return
that we might get on a typical private
sector investment but to match to rates
of return you know we look at the seven
percent return on the stock market we
look at the one percent rate of return
on the on sit on risk-free investment
and then we and then we use a modified
version of Ramses rule that accounts for
time preference for wealth effects and
for the risk premium all at the same
time and then we're fitting not one
equation and two unknowns but actually
we fit two equations and two unknowns
and so we can choose unique values for
the parameters qualitatively what's what
what happens when we move from the
deterministic Ramsey rule to the
modified Nancy's rule is that it leads
to a large increase in the value of the
parameter alpha and alpha in a model
that accounts for risk and uncertainty
represents investor risk aversion and it
represents societies version 2 22 everis
event and our calibration accounting for
the numerical magnitude of the risk
premium leads leads this this
coefficient of the elasticity of
marginal utility now is the coefficient
of relative risk aversion and we get a
value for that parameter based on market
theta but three times as large is the
value that's used in dice and the based
version of dice and we get a somewhat
higher rate of pure time preference
interestingly so in our version of this
model people are a little more impatient
but they're highly risk-averse they
really hate the the ups and downs in the
stock market which I must say that I
don't like watching the well I may
retire someday I'm doubtful but I may
retire someday so we recalibrate
preferences to account for the high
levels of risk of risk aversion that
people reveal in their market behavior
then we do then we come back and we
close the loop by taking dice and
creating a stochastic
a stochastic version of dice and there's
a lot of different on certain parameters
in our version of dice but the key
uncertainties relate first to climate
sensitivity and climate sensitivity is
the amount of the level of temperature
change caused by a doubling of
greenhouse gas concentrations a core
central estimate that's around three
degrees Celsius but when you look at it
and it used to be believed that the
climate sensitivity had a narrow normal
distribution but the recent scientific
literature shows that it actually has a
fat tail distribution and that there's
about a twenty percent chance for
example the climate sensitivity exceeds
five degrees Celsius even four percent
chance of a value in excess of 10
degrees Celsius and that's as that if we
wind up in the low probability case
where a little greenhouse gas emissions
causes a large amount of climate change
then it's easy to get positive feedback
loops we're climate change you know you
can get into a lot of trouble because
damages kick in very rapidly and you can
get economic catastrophes in a model it
has it has a really high value for
climate sensitivity the other thing is
that we make assumptions about
subjective uncertainty about the damage
function I'm not going to go into this
in detail now because I really am
running up against my time constraint
but we're but I mentioned earlier that
that in literature there's no consensus
on climate damages and that's something
that we try to model using a subjective
probability approach okay and the punch
line is what much line us that the
speaker shouldn't just flip back and
through yeah no I'm where I my mom I
didn't mean to do that that's that's
just that's just I'm yeah I'm not paying
attention to my own slide punch line is
this if we calibrate a version of glass
to account for the high level of risk
aversion that investors reveal on the
market based on the spread between the
returns on safe assets and risky assets
and we account in particular for the
four
for a fat tailed uncertainty about
climate sensitivity then the the optimal
policy scenario in our analysis me and
stabilizing climate or greenhouse gas
concentrations that around 450 parts per
million which is essentially consistent
with the Copenhagen Accord you know it's
not an immediate cessation of greenhouse
gas emissions but it's a rapid movement
away from current emissions levels it's
not because we're using ethics an
ethically based discount rate or because
we're using discount rates that that
differ for market discount rates what's
going on here is a simple as a simple
thing when we stabilize climate we are
removing the risks that go along with
with with accelerated climate change and
removing that risk provides a large very
substantial risk premium and in a sense
our model is implicitly using a low
discount rate we're using a low monetary
discount rate for for climate impacts
even though we're using a high utility
discount rate if that makes sense to you
different different things that we might
discount have different discount rates
that are literate a CH to them and our
model says that we should stabilize
climate because people people's revealed
economic decisions show that they're
highly risk averse so then maybe
actually if we account for risk and
uncertainty in the right way maybe
there's not so much difference between
market discounting approaches and in
stearns utilitarian approach I'll and
with just a couple of slides that go
back I supposed to pinch ow I'm talking
about climate and the key and the well
the Kyoto Protocol the united nations
framework convention on climate change
you know this goal of preventing
dangerous anthropogenic interference
with the climate system but really we're
talking about Thomas Jefferson who wrote
that the earth belongs and yousef rock
to the living which is a beautiful short
piece of tech
that's from the letter to James Madison
about the public debt Jefferson wanted
there to be constitutional provisions
against the accumulation of debt so the
well that that was what he was writing
about he is using this this analogy
about the earth belonging and usufruct
to the living and what that means is
that natural resources land for us
ecosystem services biodiversity are our
common joint collective property my
property it's not a vons property it's
not your property it's our property and
the US in this framing according to
jefferson isn't just people who are
living today its members of future
generations and we're entitled to take
our share to enjoy our share of the
benefits that are provided by by natural
capital by ecosystem services but we
also have a duty to a duty to to
conserve that resource for the bit for
the benefit of the other beneficiaries
future generations it some of my own
professorial efforts to try to bring
this down to the present and apply this
you know I I've written about an idea
that I call the the fair sharing
principle which is that each present
each member of present and future
society is entitled to share fairly and
the benefits derived by environmental
resources or from environmental
resources specific stocks of
environmental resources should not be
depleted without rendering just
compensation to members of future
generations and I'll say that this is an
application of an idea called the public
trust doctrine which is an idea from the
law that goes back to to Roman law by
way of the Magna Carta also say that in
that that that philosophy chapter that I
think was circulated in the readings I
develop the ways in which a commitment
to conserving natural resources for
future generations can be derived from a
concern for equality of opportunity
between contemporaries but it's a right
Bates approach and if future generations
have a right okay so we come back to the
to the applications of the approach for
climate change really for biodiversity
conservation to
now Stern's punchline in the store in
review stirring argues that failing to
stabilize climate would lead to long run
costs equivalent to five five to twenty
percent reduction in economic output the
this this the stewardship approach the
sustainability approach the sphere
sharing principled approach says that
the present generation has no right to
impose those harms on future generations
unless those unless they're compensated
Climate stabilization we can achieve at
a cost one percent of economic output
it's not sinking the economy to move
from a high carbon economy to a post
carbon economy it's a matter of changing
of Santa's and making a transition to to
a new kind of energy system that in some
ways we can vaguely see in broad outline
but that we haven't entirely mean we're
not going to get there until we start
making the doing walk right finally a
very good paper in the journal of
environmental economics and management
by Dan Bromley from 19 from 1989 wrote a
paper that that influence this
influenced my thought a lot over the
years and it's based on a legal argument
a property rule it's a situation where I
can go to court and I could get an
injunction against pavan because pavan
is is is planning some activity that
potentially might harm me and the court
is going to then issue an injunction say
pavan you cannot do that because that
would violate riches rights and property
rules are used it's a tool for
preventing harm typically courts use
typically legal systems relying on
property rules and circumstances were
the benefit derived from the action is
relatively minor and the potential harm
is incomparable with those benefits you
know so a Bromley's argument applies to
this to the ethics of intergenerational
fairness saying that preventing harms
when we're dealing with your reverse
abilities and fundamental uncertainties
then the way to go from moral
perspective is to have a rule against
inflicting and imposing harms rather
than focusing on what's called a
liability rule where Pavan is free to
act and then if I'm harmed then I can
seek damages all right I have one more
slide it's just some summary points and
we've already had a lot of discussion
but maybe there'll be a few questions
before people slip out of the room my
summary would go like this the you know
we can use we that the use of high
discount rates is appropriate for risky
investments that provide gains and
losses that accrue to the investor
personally you know so the market rates
of return represent personal values or
personal preferences about risk and
about the timing of getting payouts for
example you know but conserving
ecosystems conserving biodiversity it's
a precautionary investment you know it's
secure future it's a means of securing
future human flourishing it's a way of
reducing potentially catastrophic
irreversible risks that frankly we don't
understand at all well when we're
undertaking from a finance perspective
when we're undertaking actions or
investments that reduce rather than
enhance risk then we use low discount
rates in fact we might use a discount
rate that's even lower than the
risk-free the risk-free discount rate
which is already starting out at one
percent a third point is that following
Stern we can justify using a low
discount a low monetary discount rate if
we think that equal weight should be
attached to present and future well da
um and and finally there are I think
powerful there are certainly interesting
arguments from rights-based ethics let's
say that it's it's simply morally wrong
future generations have a right to their
share of environmental resources it's
wrong to inflict uncompensated harms of
on future generations or to deprive them
of resources to which they hold adjust
entitlement you know in the thing that's
interesting
about protecting rights is that we don't
need to make complex arguments about
exactly how much what the monetary value
is that derives from those rights you
know it this takes us in a legal
institutional direction and away from a
focus on I monetary valuation okay so
I've gone two minutes over which I'm
apologize for actually I wish they were
a little more time for some questions I
imagined some people need to run out of
the room which I would certainly
understand since it is the end of the
day but I imagine there may also be some
questions or comments